i ragazzi sono ritornati su pubblicità
giapponesi che erano poi non la faceva
effettivamente pensò che il giappone
avrà uscito nuove perle vediamo di che
si tratta soprattutto per il fatto
spero di video vi sia piaciuto perché
c'è un pesce gigante in un magazzino
qual è il problema è questo quello che
fanno quelli di amazon d'altro la sua
espressione dice tutto perché possiamo
concludere il video abbiamo finito
ragazzi questo è però io io io non posso
ritrovare a 10 secondi di video e non
sapere già che cup dire rifacciamo tutto
vi rifacciamo effetto cavazza grand bleu
papa cos'era cos'è grand bleu fantasy
era un gioco per gioco per telefono ma
barba basta ma cos'è pesa quanto la
rampa che a questo tizio per questa cosa
spero tantissimo
basta dare schiaffi basta dare schiaffi
per cortesia è colpa sua
comunque
mario cal food nel canto libero andiamo
avanti ragazzi comunque stavo dicendo
che finora si è capito tutto sin
dall'inizio di cosa parlavano strano che
il bruno mars giapponese versione
evoluta è un'invasione di zombie non ho
capito di cosa tratta la macchina o mesi
crisi minuto ma per sé ma per cento
anche se una mano è la mucca parla il
bellissimo ma che voce sexy calamità a
dirlo subito round o al live square enix
final fantasy vii vii notte
anna favi da poco cogliere stasera
domani
io ho avuto lo sguardo fisso su gli
occhi delle ragazze che come sono fatti
bene gli occhi per
[Musica]
cresce quindi da sé
non solo la storia dentro ma mi piace a
mcdonald's che starà la pubblicità del
mcdonald's vabbè andiamo avanti
giustamente è chiaro andare in giro per
il giappone decadente dei pac man robot
normalissima peserà 800 mila kg
ma sai che non sto capendo niente di
quello che so se invece sei trovato ma
non io e dio sa era perché dove lavarsi
i capelli con la con lo shampoo lucido
va bene lucida temi i capelli ragazzi
pound l'inps
gente che trova motorini a caso sale
sopra gli ruba fanno carta fornisce
sasso per chi deve rubare il motorino li
rubano tutti contenti
basta onda di one piece
le amo questi questi incidiamo questi
intermezzi di pubblicità anime
giapponesi sono delle elezioni come
pensate che dr mezzo santo ok ok anche
poi alla fine si tratta sempre di nudo
luigi d'andata matteo leclerc anna
hunger games e sei una forma di erotismo
giapponese in un bravo della spiega
un'altra volta prende un uomo crocchetta
del family mart tra l'altro ragazzi tra
l'altro ragazzi cagate di questa la
pubblicità del paul della roba fritta
delfini mar la roba fritta del family
mart farà male quanto volete ma porca
vacca che è buona ma capo negrita da mai
a buea tripla
oddio oddio bellissimo perché io questa
squadra qua di bach e allora nel in
giappone va molto il baseball che il
giappone c'è la cultura del baseball
quando andammo io e già andrea a
hiroshima fuori dal treno
vedremo questa sorta di questo miliardo
di persone di giapponesi camminare in
fila vestite tutte di rosso perché
stanno andando la partita della squadra
di rossi nei camp bellissimo
comunque tra l'altro credo che vadano
anche un sacco sorgane gli ha detto a
soreta la gente sorride ad ora alla fine
era errata bene non era volgare la
squadra madonna come i 100 mbit
tu sei davvero marshmallow by tas non mi
crudo cosa
tocca ora io non sto più più ha davanti
più non senza il si amplifica vada
rimosso circa 600 appena io e chi no
ancora ragazze che fanno facce strane
mentre mangiano anonimi avevano sì o
casini al voto nanoq anonimi ho letto
male oppure la marca di questa bibita è
una parolaccia senza le vocali di dover
funk ok se occhiali
vedo partire se quando il baseball
sciarpe hiroshima no sembra mio cugino
quello però versione giapponese non so
se non senza non ho capito niente non
hanno pagato manco una per fare il voice
over non voice over robotico ok
icona i kings new mai una foto ma se tu
mangi il cioccolato ha parlato che ti
aumenta le capacità del cervello
[Musica]
aquarius questa è l'acqua degli sportivi
regalo da loro che ti punteggio rei di
nata e buona vista di una serie rouge
destra saprei non saprei descrivere è
l'unica cosa è mia e da bere quando non
trovo l'acqua da quasi un anno che il
latte l'acquario dei pesci
madonna che figata tutto questo
fantastico quanto fatto bene
bellissimo soyinka di giotto mattera
pochino aspetta un attimo sono
bravissime giapponese siete veramente
belli ne è valsa la pena
universal studios il giappone zio e mio
papà
vabbé vabbé vabbé vabbé fermi aiuto
aiuto cosa vedo vado alla bellissimo gli
alieni l'aspetta senza età attracco i
giganti madonna a quanto fatto bene
porca vacca bellissimo l'ambiziosa serie
tv come conan di monsters coraggiosa
taylor non mi mancava lupin e mettici un
qualcosa che nell'oro e le 18 japan a
fasci di gas per forza però il problema
è che le cose durano sei anni
sempre nelle storie trovate l'attesa di
coda che abbiamo fatto io e gian
[Musica]
parte oggi pubblici da sogno simpatico
specchia mia madre a ripoli prepari nasi
pari pari pari precollina si prezioso
natura che prevede
non mi mettere nel video lo faccio pena
e dai dai per favore
[Musica]